I want to ask you
Isaac something you took a lot of anger
a lot of people on Twitter blamed you
for ho doors death and that's why I sat
the two of you together
I'd like I wanted a really awkward
conversation how did you feel about that
Twitter they got they got mad they were
sorry that's loco yeah I woke up to a
ton of new brands that way you're not
welcome here please all the why all the
f-bombs you want Christian how did you
okay how did you interpret it did you
interpret it that it was his fault well
any bitterness towards bran at all if
you're talking to me or Hodor it's two
different things I'm apparently better
towards them but Hodor I don't think
your blames you
now Christian I'm just curious first of
all that was an amazing display of love
for you what was that day like this has
been people obviously loved your
character and then the day comes that
you know that this is going to be your
last scene what was that like for you
what was the mood on set
well it's tremendously sad I've been
with these guys for seven years and I've
known Isaac since he was again he's
always lying down it was really sad I
mean I feel that gonna leave him my
friends but luckily I live in Belfast so
I will I will be torturing you guys I
heard there was a lot of unity for you
on the set that day from even the crew I
mean not just the cast but the crew as
well people were occasionally shouting
out like randomly throughout the day it
was a long shooting day happens everyday
for me you know it's everyday everyday
everywhere you go right everywhere I go
I hear it's people people hold the door
for me they
[Laughter]
you
you